au Para présent à la chasse aux fausses
informations
un faux intox est avec vous Anthony
Saint-Léger bonjour bonjour on est à 40
jours de la Coupe du monde si
controversée au Qatar une affiche à
destination des supporters fait beaucoup
jaser ah oui une affiche officielle en
tout cas interprété comme officiel et
comme venant officiellement des
autorités à être qatari et qui nous dit
quoi le Qatar vous souhaite la bienvenue
et vous le voyez elle liste ici tout un
ensemble de restrictions 8 au total
comme par exemple le fait de boire de
l'alcool d'être homosexuel de ne pas
faire preuve de décence ou encore tout
simplement le simple fait de se
rencontrer cette affiche elle a été
diffusée il y a une dizaine de jours et
elle est devenue virale on la retrouve
sur de très nombreux réseaux sociaux et
d'entrée de de très nombreuses langues
que ce soit en anglais on le voit ici
cette internaute ironise le Qatar vous
souhaite la bienvenue mais pas toi pas
toi pas toi ni toi cet autre aussi cette
fois en espagnol qui se pose la question
mais à quel moment le s'est dit qu'il
allait organiser une coupe du monde il y
a des réactions aussi en arabe ou même
en français ici cette internaute par
exemple de comparer le Qatar au
Moyen-âge et de faire référence à
l'esclavage et toute cette polémique
autour des ouvriers décédés dans la
construction des stades et de se poser
la question mais on a même pas le droit
de se rencontrer ou encore cet autre
toujours en français ils vont s'éclater
pour la Coupe du monde et pour terminer
cette ce membre de reconquête voyons
comment se porte le droit à la
différence au Qatar alors autant le
préciser cette affiche n'est pas un
montage elle est authentique
effectivement elle existe bel et bien
mais elle ne provient pas des autorités
avec qatari on va la regarder à nouveau
ensemble il y avait un indice dans cette
affiche et cet indice il est ici
regardez c'est ce logo pourquoi parce
que grâce à ce logo en faisant une
recherche d'image inversée on va arriver
sur ce compte Twitter regardez en
l'occurrence RyR
montre ton respect une association
ultra conservatrice qui bien avant le
mondial de cette année dit vouloir vous
le voyez c'est écrit ici participer à la
consolidation des valeurs islamiques qui
soutiennent l'identité
qatarienne préservée donc les valeurs
face à la mauvaise influence que
pourrait être avoir les touristes et les
étrangers de manière générale une
association qui annonce la couleur on va
découvrir ensemble quelques
visuels de campagne ou même celui-ci par
exemple alors celui de droite dit non au
naturisme et puis celui de gauche c'est
une campagne en ligne de juillet dernier
contre les LGBTQ et vous le voyez là où
ce dessin vante finalement l'amour coûte
que coûte quel que soit le genre cet
autre répond quitte à ce qui est de
l'eau de l'eau c'est de l'eau alors
pourquoi pas boire l'eau des toilettes
voilà pour ce comparatif assez doute on
va revenir au visuel qui nous intéresse
ce soir en l'occurrence celui-ci et bien
on le retrouve ce visuel le 1er octobre
dans le compte Twitter en question avec
donc ce hashtag du nom de la campagne et
du nom de l'association mais cette
campagne elle est bien plus ancienne
elle date de 2014 ou de 2012 avec un
autre nom l'objectif étant d'expliquer
aux étrangers la vision de l'association
quand on respecte des mœurs au
Qatar et parce que justement avec ce
visuel de nombreuses personnes sont
tombées dans le panneau faisant en
croyant qu'il s'agissait d'autorité
qatari et bien figurez-vous que le
compte officiel du Mondial a aidé du
comité cathari de l'organisation de
l'événement ont publié un communiqué
commun dans lequel ils expliquent bien
que ce visuel n'a absolument rien
d'officiel et de préciser d'ailleurs que
prochainement un guide à destination des
fans sera publié pour autant aller
supporter du Mondial Anthony seront bien
soumis à des restrictions imposées par
les autorités du Qatar effectivement
parce que si le Qatar est présenté ici
comme un pays ouvert
tolérant et accueillant évidemment les
miracs est connu pour son ultra
conservatisme et leur on le sait est à
la polémique alors quelles sont les
restrictions en vigueur dans le pays
alors d'abord pour ce qui est de
l'habillement et bien il faudra abhorer
une tenue tout à fait modeste même si
l'esprit s'est écrit ici est décontracté
mais que ce soit pour les hommes ou les
femmes vous le voyez les épaules et les
genoux doivent de toute façon être
couverts maintenant pour ce qui est de
l'alcool et bien l'alcool est-il
autorisé au Qatar oui mais à une
condition à deux conditions plus
précisément il est interdit de boire en
public et il faut être âgé de plus de 21
ans pour ce qui est du Mondial il est
l'usage et la vente de l'alcool est
strictement encadrée et en l'occurrence
la consommation et la vente ne pourront
se faire que dans les fans officielles
de la FIFA entre 18h30 et du matin et
enfin pour ce qui est des couples à la
fois non mariés ou de même sexe ou de
sexe différent
voilà je m'y perds voilà et bien d'une
part il est interdit de s'embrasser en
public en revanche qu'il soit marié ou
non qu'il soit homosexuel ou non ils
pourront dormir dans la même chambre
d'hôtel voilà ce qui reste dans la
chambre bah restera dans la chambre
merci beaucoup Anthony c'était info
intox avec Anthony